It's a big, sprawling space saga of rebellion and romance.
Carrie Fisher was just 19 when her role as Princess Leia in the original Star Wars movie...
...made her an international star.
She reprised the part in several followup versions over the decades.
Fisher was a child of Hollywood,...
...the daughter of a film star and a popular singer who encouraged her to perform.
Aside from film acting, Fisher wrote several semi-autobiographical novels,...
...memoirs and a one-woman play in which she dealt openly with her drug addictions...
...and struggles with bipolar disorder.
Fisher once said she would have turned down her first role in Star Wars...
...if she had known it would make her a celebrity like her parents,...
...which complicated their lives.
But this year, Harvard University students awarded her a Lifetime Achievement Award...
...for her activism and outspokenness...
...in advancing public discussion of addiction and mental illness.